hey guys today i'm going to share some
ideas on posing females
hi my name is jerry gionis i'm a wedding
portrait and fashion photographer i've
been photographing for 27 years and
teaching for 20. i'm going to share some
of that experience with you right now
and show you how to go from this to this
when it comes to posing females and
don't forget click on the link below or
right up here to download my portrait
quick start and enjoy for free
so right now we're going to discuss
posing tips for women girls ladies
whatever your preferred word is is
totally fine with me how do you bring
out the best in a girl well she's
standing in front of you she's waiting
for a good shot
but you have to direct her you have to
bring out the best in there now even
though rainy is gorgeous he's got a
great figure again it does take someone
to bring out the best in whoever you're
photographing so if we were just
standing flat-footed there rainey right
to the camera well this looks like we're
about to we're on a firing squad this is
just a very basic way of photographing
someone it's a bit predictable so what
we want to do is this we want to create
some form we want to bring out the shape
now what defines the male form in my
humble opinion is chest and shoulders
what defines the female form of course
are curves so we want to bring out those
curves
so first of all i want you never to ever
stand flat footed no matter who it is
even if you're photographing a 12 year
old girl whether you're photographing a
corporate female ceo executive i find
it's just very static for for a woman
or a girl to stand like this and of
course of course these posing ideas have
to be age appropriate depending on who
you're photographing at the very least
all we do is put the feet together and
bring one foot in front of the other one
knee in front of the other part of me so
this will even work with a 12 year old
girl if you sort of overly bring out
sort of shape it's not going to be
appropriate now
let's say a female corporate ceo
executive you might want to add a bit of
softness over here but then a bit of
strength in the arms and you might get
it to lean forward like this and all of
a sudden we're showing femininity but
also strength and dependence fantastic
now when it comes to let's say
complimenting a model or or a late
teenager or a bride or whatever it might
be
these tips are going to be invaluable
for you
so
let's talk about this first of all the
easiest way that you can actually pose
someone is really not saying a word at
all and here's what we're going to do
we'll do a demonstration now i'm going
to just say one little piece of advice
to reigning and she'll follow my
perspective here let's basically stand
about this far apart fantastic and all i
want you to do is mirror me okay you
ready
perfect
easy you see how easy that was now yes
rainey has worked with me before she
basically knows how i like to pose and
it was easier from that perspective but
i am telling you 100
the more you get people to marry you the
easier it is going to be for actually
for people to to to understand what you
want now posing does not have to be a
dirty word the the minute you say i'm
going to pose you people like oh it's a
bit stuffy it's
it implies a very mechanical sort of way
of moving but here's the thing you ask a
simple question to whoever you're
photographing and i might say raining as
beautiful as you are i can make you
shine brighter than ever before with a
simple direction would you like that
absolutely of course so no one's going
to say no make me look ugly than i
already am thank you very much
everyone's going to want to look great
so you give people a logical reason as
to what you're doing and why you're
doing it that's a really important part
of the process so educating your client
as to what you're doing and why you're
doing it otherwise if it just feels
awkward which sometimes posing does
then they're not going to feel good
about it therefore it's going to be a
problem remember though women will do
anything for beauty you have to
understand that so again please educate
whoever you're photographing in front of
your camera as to what you're doing and
why you're doing it now so what we said
before that we want to at least put the
weight of the body sort of one way or
the other that's a good start for us but
let's start from the beginning how would
we pose a girl to bring out curves
in a in a very systematic kind of a way
so here's what we do
we turn the body on a bit of an angle
okay
so now what we like to do is so if
you're mirroring me like you are point
your toe towards the camera
slide the heel back in
bend the knee
shoulders back
lean the chest forward and then arms off
the body
so what we're doing now guys you see
this beautiful curve i almost look
prettier than you but that's okay
that's another tutorial but what's
happening here is we're bringing out her
beautiful curves so let me have a look
from this perspective yep great angle
great curves everything's looking really
really good now do you notice something
else
posing is not just posing for the sake
of posing it is you have to have to pose
according to the light source
now in previous tutorials i would have
discussed actually very specifically
lighting for women so give you a a quick
little elevator pitch on what i'm
talking about is this the direction of
lights coming from here it's an open
garage door could be likened to a big
window light so what i like to do is
turn the body away from the light source
until we get a shadow on the cleavage
middle of the dress
then
so now her left leg is closer to the
camera the leg that's closest to the
camera is usually the one that you'll
always bend in other words the weight
distribution will be on her back leg so
she puts all her weight in the back leg
if she's doing it correctly she can lift
her up her front leg no problem so now
we're good now also we said hands on the
hips for this particular argument here
and according to the light we turn her
face and then turn it to the light and
then her eyes can go back to the camera
so when you pose a girl with the chin to
the outer shoulder with eyes back it's
considered very feminine so we've got
that that works for us
so now that we understand the foundation
of the female form let's get a bit more
specific
so let's just unravel again if you just
stand normally with your hands by your
side now you don't really have that
problem but usually there'll be little
pinches of skin that will hang over the
dress that's an issue especially if
you're wearing an evening gown and as we
get older skin loosens up a little bit
that's just the nature of of who we are
as humans but if you want to eliminate
that eliminate those little pinches of
skin all you have to do is actually
bring the shoulders back and the arms
off the body now here's the thing when
you bring a body part on another body
part you flatten it so in this case i
have very small arms now i make up with
it my height and my brain but anyway
so if you bring your arm against the
body it looks bigger and flatter so for
a girl
it's a touching point for girls girls do
not like their arms looking big
see here's the thing guys have three
problems we have problems with our gut
being big our double chin bald head
women
everything that's
women are conscious about everything one
of the sour points is the arm looking
bigger so you always have to understand
to bring the arms off the body you have
to give her an excuse to bring your arms
off her body it could be holding your
hands up it could be holding her hair it
could be for a bride it could be holding
the veil out it could be anything just
bring her arms off her body even if it's
like this and back at least it's
something
so
also what
what else happens when you actually
bring the shoulders back of whoever
you're photographing well let's let's
watch so just come down back again if
you bring your shoulders back
now what happens is the bust looks
fuller and firmer
every girl is going to want their bus to
look fuller and firmer so shoulders back
like this if you do have a girl with a
really big bust and you want to soften
that you can do the uh the inverted bust
like you could that that horrible pose
for some reason is being popularized by
models all over the world everyone just
does this
this only looks good really for my
opinion over the shoulder and not so
much like this but if you have a girl
with a big bust and you want to swallow
that bust up a little bit that's when
you make it concave
okay not convex
all right so how else can we make the
bust look fuller and firmer other than
just bringing the shoulders back well
let's do this so just stand normally
okay looking at the camera there on the
count of three i want you to breathe in
fully one two three
so you see that her bust is looking
fuller and firmer by doing that also
if you want to emphasize something
you'll push it towards the camera and
towards the light in this case
i'm saying that if we want the bus to
look fuller and firm out we bring the
shoulders back we can breathe in but
ultimately if you turn your body a
little bit more away like this a bit
more
point the toe towards the camera again
slide the heel back in bend the knee
shift your weight back shoulders back
now hands on the hips from one moment
and now lean your chest forward this way
and then turn your face towards the
light and eyes back at the camera
so do you see how her bust looks fuller
and firmer in that way as well so we
have three ways of doing that short of
actually going in photoshop and
using all those tools that can actually
make body parts look bigger or smaller
but we can do it in camera and of course
if we can why wouldn't we
okay let's talk about something else now
so we've talked about the bust we've
talked about shoulders we've talked
about the body positioning with the feet
let's talk about hands
now guys hands are the most expressive
thing after the eyes so you have to do
something with them why would you waste
that form of expression so my suggestion
to you is understand how you pose them
well
let's start with this the best example
that i can give you with hands is if you
bring your hands like this bring your
hands on your biceps and then roll your
wrists around like this
what happens is that that is the way you
pose hands it's a very delicate soft
little bend now so randy if you're happy
to just bring your hands out like this
and if you can sort of see how where our
hands are both being mirrored now go
right back and then put them right back
into place
so if for example if she was holding a
champagne glass that's the way you'd be
holding it you wouldn't want to hold it
like that
if she was holding let's say
her partner's arm it wouldn't be like
that it'll be like this remember we said
here
here
here
nice and soft now bring your hand up
like this and just let it go
so right now rainy and i are not
thinking about our hands we're not
tensing our hands we're supporting our
hand with our arms and elbows so this is
basically it now you see how it's
gradually going up to a point it's
considered very delicate and as i do
this do you notice how my pinky goes up
and this goes up
it's always considered like a ballet
pose when you're holding something
this is what you want you've got to take
the air out a little bit so for me if
you ever forget about posing my
suggestion is so if we're looking at
this uh this white camera if we're
looking at this
i want you to remember that posing is
like a balloon so if i was to let's say
for example you're a balloon and we were
blowing ourselves up like
really stiff and now let the air out
and then you would naturally of course
turn to me and you would point the toe
and bend the knee
makes sense so you're stretching it out
or you're just relaxing it
so that's how easy posing can be is when
you understand who you're photographing
as far as the female form being able to
turn the body away from the light and
the face back in
we point the toe to the camera
shift the weight back slide the heel
back in shoulders back lengthen the
chest forward that is going to be the
foundation to the female pose
and when it comes to hands and arms you
need to give an excuse to wherever
you're photographing like i said to
bring your hands off her body now what
else could she do she could basically
hold her hair so let's get your hair on
one side
and then you could sort of hold your
hair very delicately like this
right perfect all right so guys let's do
this let's put all that information
together take a couple of shots and put
our theory into practice let's do it
so now we're giving you a little bit of
theory now let's put it into practice to
take a couple of shots to give you an
idea of how we can execute all these
ideas so right now actually stay where
you're already i love that because
you're standing very flat-footed you're
sort of your body language is suggesting
um like hurry the hell up i want to go
right now
which might happen with a girl that
you're photographing and that's okay so
what we want to do is we want to disarm
her a little bit
so just take the arm away a little bit
okay so disarm or disarm
now we basically said the importance of
turning the body away from the light
source and the face back in as well as
combining it with that classic
foundation of that full length female
pose so what we'll do turn your body
slightly away from the light that's it
point your toe towards me mirror me
that's it slide the heel back in bend
the knee
shoulders back
and then you can put your hands on your
hips for the moment and now turn your
body a little bit more towards the light
just a little bit there we go
okay good and now turn your face towards
the light bit more
gorgeous hold it
eyes at me beautiful turn your chin more
to your outer shoulder again
gorgeous hold it there for me hold it
turn your bring your back heel more that
way that's it there you go too much
so so bring that hill back no there you
go good hold it there
beautiful
now let's say for example with this
particular shot
she's got her hands on her hips and you
might say well where do we place those
hands on the hips because there's many
ways to do it the web of your hand
should be at the thinnest part of the
waist if you also basically have a plus
size girl you could hold the bulk of the
weight underneath underneath her hand
because the illusion is she's actually
that thin but it's cutting away but
traditionally the web of the hand going
in the thinnest part of her waist
now so now that we've established the
full length shot if we don't like the
idea of the left hand being in the image
and it being a sort of a little bit
distracting we have to do something with
it so rainy put all your hair on this
side if you're happy too and then hold
your hair very gently using those
delicate hands that we had perfect
that's beautiful hands hands on the hips
actually stay there because that's a bad
version of a pose okay hold it there
you see how she's shifting go back again
she's shifting her weight the opposite
way
that doesn't work because now she almost
looks bow legged i'm not too sure what
the correct term for that is um and it
looks weird and the shadows are falling
a bit weirdly
on her dress now she turns
we hold the dress gorgeous turn the face
towards the light eyes at me beautiful
hold it
gorgeous
now one leg is covering the other that's
totally fine we don't have to see every
body part especially by the nature of
the pose if it's suitable or not in this
case i want to create curves so when i
see a peak i want to see a valley
honestly a peak i want to see a valley
no different than seeing her bust
and then going down and then the peak
and then the valley and so on and so on
the more curves we see the more
beautiful it's going to be now here's a
problem if you could have everything all
curvaceous and one anomaly like a
straight arm or a straight hand holding
something
it looks weird watch this so if you get
that beautiful curves back again
and then i want you to bring your hand
let's pretend like you're holding
something with this right hand
then now we've got beautiful curves in a
figure
but then that hand is dangling down
being really straight so what we want to
do is we want to slightly sort of bend
that hand whether it's within the body
whether it's sort of up here you have to
give her something to do
now in this case let's come a little bit
closer to take a couple of shots by
using those hands as we discussed so
ronnie if you want to face me there
now let's do the hands pose that we did
before so let's start like this
so flat that's good hold it there
good and now roll the wrists around
good luck and relax those fingers about
a bit more perfect good
and then shoulders back
good hold it there
now turn your body away from the light
stop there point your toe towards me
slide the heel back in bend the knee
shift the weight back lean the chest
forward good and then turn the face that
chin to the outer shoulder
good tilt more turn the chin more to the
shoulder
good okay beautiful and now we've got a
great way of posing hands
beautiful okay relax
so remember too that curves are really
important as we've discussed but if you
can bend a body part bend it especially
on a woman of course so you never want
this being straight if you can
like the hand is joint to the wrist you
want that bent the elbow never straight
it's always bent the legs never straight
always bent and so on and so forth that
makes a huge difference
so for example if you're introducing the
hands up into the face let's say for
example you're adjusting your earrings
so don't think about it just do it sort
of naturally how would you adjust your
earrings with both hands
okay stop there
so if you see her now you see how
although she's actually we're shooting
on a thinner part of the wrist it's
actually shooting more like this so just
even emphasize it more this way good
okay good as in bad okay hold it there
okay now here's a good way of
remembering it if you want let's say a
shot of a girl adjusting the earrings
simply bring the wrists together like
this and now turn your face towards a
light and adjust your earring like this
perfect chin down
lean towards the light remember we said
arms off the body we don't make the arms
look big or flat
good and turn your face a bit more
towards a light rainy
good nice profile beautiful hold it
now switch your body weight if you look
at your legs there so that's it now
bring that right knee over the other one
good and turn your hips more left other
way
good huge difference chin down hold it
there
arm off the body one last time good hold
it
beautiful
it's all micro movements that's what
it's all about so guys
my suggestion is
i don't want you to actually go and
actually photograph a girl
a younger girl an older girl a woman or
whatever like that and have no game plan
you must understand the foundation of
the female pose what did we say point
the toe towards the camera slide the
heel back in push the weight on the back
leg shoulders back lean the chest
forward arms off the body
that will be your best friend tattoo it
on your face if you have to backwards so
when you look in the mirror it reads
correctly so make sure you do that
well and remember the nuances of hands
if you forget how to pose hands remember
just do this relax that and that's how
you would pose a hand on a face do that
turn that around that's how you would
pose a hand on a rail or or a bench of a
girl and so on and so forth just
remember simply bring out the best in
anyone that you're photographing and
remember repetition experience and
practice will be your best teacher
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed that video
also do me a favor give me a thumbs up
please subscribe and don't forget to
click on that bell for notifications of
future episodes also leave me a comment
i'd love to hear from you answer any of
your questions and stay connected and
remember you don't have to be the best
you just got to be better than last week